um oh it's a good question
um
yes and no
um because you've got two sides to a
coin so you've got some men will say
that women are frigid or on op aren't
sexually open because they withhold
having sex from someone which then could
make someone say oh okay so in order for
me to prove affection to someone I must
now mean I have to speak with people so
it's got two sides to be coin but I
think it does have an impact yeah so can
I get a yes or no is it man's fault yes
or no
I don't think it's fair to say is
therefore in Titan whose fault is it
more is it the women or the man yeah
yeah I would say men's well it's more
men's fault yeah I think that women
sleep around yeah okay go ahead
I'm 50 50. now we gotta pick one whose
fault is it that the women are sleeping
because I feel like
like we are in control of our own
actions so like I said are you sure she
thinks the men are in control of our
actions no but I just feel like you
yourself you're in control of your own
actions so you can't really blame
someone else for doing the actions that
you're wanting to doing so I can't
really say it's men's fault but at the
same time just the way Society is and
how
everything has become so
sexualized and like men like to push
women I just do feel like yeah whose
fault I can't is that what you call a
360. we got a yeah
um I wouldn't say no it's women's fault
no I need you it's mental it's man's
fault okay what about you I'm 50 50 but
if I had to pick it'll be it's the
woman's fault it's free will okay yeah
what do you think Auntie it's a woman
because the man can't have sex unless
she opens her legs end off
is it okay so if you hooked up with
Drake whose fault would it be would it
be Drake's fault or your fault that's a
black and white question though because
it's not just as bad it's mixed race
as simple as saying if because you did
it it's your fault there's there's
different aspects to it and then there's
the emotional um
your faults are Drake's fault it's a
mutual decision we both had sex 55 who's
who's fault there is no one's fault in
that situation if you want to be black
and white with it it's no one's fault
who who's in control of sex
we by far you both are who who has to
say yes to sex both do both have to
consent okay if you hook up with Drake
whose fault is it
um it's your own fault you decided to do
what you wanted to do with Drake's oh we
got her so now you're on you're on the
other it's the women's fault
50 50 because it's just hard to say but
yeah if you want to steam and drink then
yeah that's your old fault yeah I think
I think that it's a hundred percent the
women's fault 100 because it's like all
right all right yeah you put a piece of
meat in front of a tiger you can't be
mad he ate it you put the piece of meat
right in front of him
now I know everyone will say pearl don't
control compare women to me
but I will I just
now yeah because men are in control of
relationships women are in control of
sex so we pick who we sleep with men who
pick who they wife you think that's true
false I think it's true nothing is true
for the majority oh so do we switch
teams you're back on my side it's the
women's fault
no I don't switch teams but that
particular statement I do agree with
okay
um would what percent of men do you
think are having sex
that are sexually active
it's called it's got to be High
um at least 90 90 or 75 75 7A
40 40. what if I told you one in three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year
brothels I always think about brothels
oh no I think they just do the corn
thing what's the corn thing like I can't
say that oh YouTube
okay who's saying oh my God because
medical high sex drive and they're not
getting it I mean that must be hard for
them because the women are freeing them
to the wrong people yeah but I I was
thinking a lot of men go to like
brothels and stuff like pay for it these
days and then plus some people ain't got
the gut so just stay at home you
miserable have a weight yeah well it's
like why do you think women hate man
we're all sleeping with the same ones
what percent what percent of men do you
think are over six foot nice not high at
all yeah I think it's like twenty thirty
percent Thirty thirty percent fifteen
wow
in a certain amount of money that's got
to be like 0.5
Idris Elba basically um yeah I don't
find him sexy as well okay
um do you guys think that men wife
yeah yeah 100 do you think the
men that wife the know that
they're horse yeah yeah they do know
definitely what do you think yeah
because I think to most men what I'm
learning is that if you see if anybody
other than him
your whole so yeah okay with the girls
so how many girls can you think of that
are that have gotten married
well the first one that comes to mind is
cardi B like I mean she used to oh I met
in your personal life now
celebrities kind of live in a different
world like I don't I don't think we can
compare cardi B to the average gal so
how many people do I know that a horse I
got married yeah
at least six okay and what about do
their husbands know yeah and they don't
care probably not no okay yeah none of
my friends are married so you wouldn't
because you're young how old did you say
you were 23 yeah okay okay yeah I think
I don't know many people that got
married but majority of yeah
they've been married yeah so a lot what
do you mean they don't get married no
I've got fussy male friends
okay I'm gonna read the super chats
really quick before I get into the next
question
guys
the super chats have been better this
show they have been better so make sure
you guys like the video how many likes
do we need to get to a thousand what are
we trying to save for right now blessing
what what are you trying to buy what
equipment are you trying to run me dry
with
what are you what are you trying to do
to me now you trying to get Amber Rose
here to do a one-on-one interview guys
so super chat for that we're on 2000
lakhs today
did you did you open the chat for him
yeah you didn't you didn't Gaslight them
did you none sometimes blessing
gaslights the chat no no they're free
today they've been excellent
okay okay
um all right guys let me all right
culture
um if you want to know what men are
looking for what for watch the guy with
the it's me channel um AO stupid it's
mind-blowing that every day women choose
to end up that women's choices do end up
being men's fall act your age see
Dumbledore for the only way 304s are
above average is in their BMI
um kawari men are like cheese never more
than five varieties at a time where they
will spoil um each cherish for the
individual they are they're lovers but
true friends